tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
meraviglioso video family friendly su
youtube italia e oggi siamo qua per
analizzare un problema insomma che
affligge il mio animo da sempre dalla
realtà da 23 anni
c'è un nuovo youtuber che sta
raggiungendo vette altissime su youtube
che supererà pd pie che si chiama ecco
come lo cos'è ecco come l'on
per farvi capire come l'on e questo mi
fa sempre ridere bellissima li facciamo
[Musica]
e come sarà lo youtuber che è stato
portato si integrano insomma la
piattaforma è arrivato a superare più di
pai così poco tempo vediamo insomma al
dito allora c'è un
c'è un ragno nel nella un ragno della
schiacciata il ragno nella vannoni non è
vero che erano e sono utilizzati né c'è
un ragno c'è un ragno nella vasca online
no c'è un ragno nella vas mappe stato il
ragno bravo pesta ragno non è così che
si questo rai di ragni fanno schifo di
ragni fanno schifo anni non sono
per angelo fanno passare da terra ogni
giorno un bambino che sguazza con un
ragno nella vasca c'è un ragno enorme
nella vasca ragazzi che adesso sta
volando però non so se insomma il canale
ma che schifo
ma no ma non è vero spider man a venezia
il bayern ha allora non funziona così
non funziona che sarà questo rania la
casa di chiunque sarebbe invasa da grani
e in chi le persone se ne sono andate
entrata la bambina latenti schiaccia per
favore schiaccia soragno non muore
schiacciate lo fate qualcosa
c'è un abbiamo dei problemi comunque
[Musica]
io credo effettivamente che comunque i
ragni a prescindere non siano a
guardarli mentre ti lavi i denti o cose
del genere
ecco è morto perfetto ma si è accorta
che c'è un ragno lasciano affogare no
allora funzionato finalmente ecco se io
fossi nato ai tempi di youtube elementi
a quest'ora non avaya fobia di ragni
perché mi avrebbero fatta passare di te
bene allora salviamo i ragni ragazzi
sappiamo i ragni quando vedete da in
casa li prendete in mano li accarezzate
egli portate fuori noli schiacciate i
ragni in realtà sono io che sbaglio
cioè io non li schiaccia perché mi cadde
addosso però ne sa che il discorso
ragazze che negli ultimi anni negli
ultimi due tre anni tre anni buoni
youtube è diventata una piattaforma
anche per chi è il pubblico chi va a
sovrastare ma in una maniera
esponenziale va per la maggiore
penso che ne siate accorti il pubblico e
standard di youtube che c'era prima
quindi gli scarichi stanno asfaltando
tutti e la cosa è strana scelse mago
come lo non è solo l'unico perché
comunque anche gli ultimi tre anni
stanno avendo successo sia meno ma
cocomero non è mica l'unico ad avere un
canale che a me sta incredibilmente a
correre blippy a ragazzi che blippy
blippy e questo canale che fa cose
education adesso vi facciamo vedere un
video di bp per che bp è incredibile
eccolo qua
[Musica]
la tipa era veramente klinge ata nel
momento blip io credo sia meraviglioso
perché su youtube
lui è in gran parte il fatto che si
mostri qua c'entra il dj o lo invidio
perché il pari host e cosa veramente
felice ma noi intanto il posto è lui che
parla insomma drink guarda che skill
perché è mio è il mio atleta preferito è
nata ragazzi di lippi mi più in lui e
blick il web lippi
facciamo vedere invece la reaction che
ha fatto marco marino acciaio i primi
dal vivo fermi
segui live lo voglio pesca totali
apro sta gonfiando aspetta quindi deve
aspettare che i conti a marley live ma
non è una è una fake live ma non vale
avevano fatto un video io e marco ai
tempi su insomma sulla reaction sub
lippi e vi faccio vedere un attimo la
scelta la sede persa è questa
tocca a lui blippy clip in poche parole
un animatore un educatore virtuale va
detto che a pirlo scritto 100 milioni di
views ma di video sto stronzo da così
tanti che arriviamo
e questo è il perché conosco blippy
perché effettivamente marco mi ha dato
insomma modo di scoprire 7 miliardi
quasi visse quindi il doppio delle mie
ma anche blip i tories blick e spagnole
bp da cpp in portoghese bbb arabo no ti
prego fire di pietro che cacchio non ho
capito niente però è tutto così bello
comunque siamo arrivati al punto in cui
effettivamente ci faccia una domanda ma
esistono canali italiani che fanno roba
del genere oltre mai contro teoricamente
sto dicendo e vediamo insomma youtuber
da bambini filtro baby challenge mike
scioscia perfetto voglio vedere che
cacchio hai fatto perché mi sono visto
nella copertina mai vediamo se questo
video deve sfociare in un gissing o che
cacchio dobbiamo fare bene vediamo
diapers.com il primo youtuber gianpi è
giovanissimo te lo dico ok è però il
nostro capo cioè proprio grazie mila
andate a lavarmi il bagno per favore che
un po sporcato prima no scherzavo
ovviamente non sono il capo di nessuno
tranne che insomma di giampiero che sta
montando di domanda schiavi sembrava
proprio perché aveva capito che già il
capo di youtube
ok a vedere i civili più vecchi
probabilmente troverai una versione
valigia è molto simile ma anche adesso
perché sono alijev no scherzo ma cosa
che vale già ampi pure tu ma che cos'è
sto è un po proprio la metà di 24 tra
quindi cosa faccia quando il tema vj te
lo giuro frasi ma lui va il pari lo zio
al capi seria e lo porta a porta che noi
cresce cacciatori è infatti è quello sì
stavo per dirlo io
va bene allora fabbisogno delle come
dexter la piccola ecco meglio se non
volete va bene ragazzi allora comunque
tutto sto disco ringrazio mike scioscia
per aver detto che
insomma sembra uguale da bambino perché
effettivamente un solo bambino anche 80
anni donne
approfittatene comunque quello che
volevo dire in chiusura e che comunque
lo so ma youtube negli ultimi anni è
andato un po verso il mondo chi si è
visto ma questo non vuol dire che io non
debba continuare a fare quello che
faccio insomma perché comunque molti si
orientano verso il kit io avete visto
prima completi purtroppo mi kringe non
sono in grado di farlo tacere ma anche
perché comunque youtube è la mia
passione oltre che mio lavoro non sempre
letto tempo lo ribadisco e continuerò a
farlo per questo la mia vita quindi che
io mi devo divertire io non riuscirei
mai a fare i contenuti così per insomma
a integrarmi all'algoritmo capito
piuttosto faccio meno virus nel periodo
perché avete ha visto l'assestamento che
c'è stato difesa anche dovuto al fatto
che ora sono subentrati canali kids
ma non parlo dei mei contro trenitalia
parlo in generale sprigioni generale ai
ragazzi un problema molto più grave del
kids che è il caldo in questo vento
stavano delicato non so se si vede vado
a farmi una doccia fredda mentre guardo
i libri lippi io vado a fare una doccia
hanno bisogno che iscritte il canale
lasciate un commento vi piace e noi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo è la
ragazza
[Musica]